[Music]
what is up guys in today's video I'll be
giving you some tips and tricks on how
to flip more easily more specifically
I'm be showing you guys items that I
recommend you flip when you're not 100
percent sure on how to flip properly if
you have not flipped before this video
is going to help you tremendously if you
have flipped before this video is still
going to help you so I do recommend you
watch it it might give you some tips
that you don't know about and also this
is episode one of my top 5 series I plan
on making many more so if you guys have
any suggestions on some top 5s you want
me to do go ahead and leave it in the
comments section and let's get started
into the video so my tip number one is
buying items in bulk so here I am buying
an item that is frequently traded cold
and as you can see I bought it for 222
and I sold it for 217 so the reason why
I'm doing this is to get the margin so
the difference between 217 and 222 is 5
so that means I can make 5gp
per coli cell so the idea is is you want
to buy it for the price that you sold it
for and you want to sell it for the
price you bought it for so you want to
sell high and buy low so once you find
an item with a margin you like go ahead
and buy the max amount if it's traded
often like Kohl's so with Cole it's
13,000 so I went ahead and bought 13,000
for the low price so I found another
item with 3gp margin that you can buy in
bulk and it's trade an opt-in so I went
ahead and bought 30,000 of the iron ore
as well so I found another item with a
4gp margin it is the cannon ball the
cannonballs trade a lot so with these
items you want to be buying in bulk you
want to be buying items that are traded
quite often so I went ahead and put in
an offer for those as well so when you
were buying in bulk and selling and
flipping fast not all items are going to
buy because the margins change almost
instantly so with the iron or I went
ahead and just declined it so once your
item buys go ahead and collect it in
this case you can only buy 7,000
cannonballs so go ahead and check your
margins and go ahead and sell it for the
price I'm going to check them
again just to make sure I'm typing in
the right number okay and then put it in
and then go ahead and sell it and wait
so the Cannonball is sold about a minute
later so with this kind of flipping it
flips really quick you just got to make
sure you stay on top of the margin so as
you can see in a few minutes I made 30k
very easily I'm going to go ahead and
cancel this offer for the sake of video
because I want to sell these quickly so
again check the margin and then put the
item in for the high price and then just
wait for them to sell so this is an
example of what I was talking about the
margins constantly changed so I noticed
the margin had changed so now I'm going
to have to put them in for that offer
sometimes you have to undercut people
but that changes the price pretty
drastically so you've got to be careful
with undercutting otherwise you'll
change the price of the item entirely
when you're selling in bolts so those
ended up selling for 221 so as you can
see from my history I made about 50k and
15 minutes so it's very easy to do
flipping bulk items I highly recommend
you do bulk items when you're starting
out when you're buying items in bulk
it's important to look at the top items
that are trading in runescape
I look at oh s body online in their
exchange it's free and you can just look
at the top items that are traded for
this video I did it very quickly but
when I normally do bulk items I can make
anywhere between 100 and 500 K an hour I
highly recommend you do this but be
careful when undercutting because you
can mess up the margins my second tip is
binding item and changing it into a
different item so for example the
serpentine viscid I buy it and then I
quickly take my chisel out of my bank
you need like 58 fletching to do this
turn it into a serpentine home uncharged
and then sell it
sells instantly and then as you can see
I just made 50k in literally seconds so
you can do that again by the serpent
envisage make the serpentine home and
then sell it again for an instant 50k
another similar item you can do this
with is the tanzanite Fang as you can
see I bought it for two million seven
hundred fifty one thousand and then I
quickly turned it into a toxic blowpipe
I let it sit in the GE for two seven
eight zero K and I started a timer and
it instantly sold within 13 seconds for
an easy 30 K profit another way to do
this is turning them into solar scales
so I bought two serpentine Helms and I
went ahead and dismantled them into
solar scales each one dismantles into
twenty thousand and I put them in for
and I waited for them to sell and
they're already selling so they ended up
selling for just over five point five ml
in about two minutes and it made about
40k so it is super easy profit to buy
items and then turn them into other
items and flip them for more money my
next tip is buying items overnight and
then selling them at a later point for
more money so I buy some of my favorite
items the Gothic cloak is one of them a
bite from 53 K to see what the top price
is and I notice it doesn't even sell for
35 K so that's almost a 20 K margin that
it's not going for so I decided to try
to sell this one for 60 K
and then I decide
by ten more of them for 37k and hopes
that they will be sold by the morning
another item that I like to flip for a
little bit of profit is the wizard boots
because they fluctuate very heavily
another item that I like to do is to
smoke battle staff
I use iOS buddy so chose me
that I should that the item normally
sells for so that is really helpful
another item that I noticed that
fluctuates a lot is the iron knife
right here it's a very slow margin but
most the time there's a way bigger
margin so I decided to put in an offer
for a bunch of them for 45 coins
another item but obviously I
this video is a serpentine this is I try
to buy it for a lower price line or we
buy it for I try to put an offer for two
but I don't have enough money after a
little bit of searching I decide that I
will try to buy the book of law for a
low price because this price does
fluctuate a lot and if I can get it for
this low of a price I can flip for much
higher price later so in the morning
most of the items bought I didn't expect
the gun fix clip to sell but I was
hopeful and the serpentine Vistage in
the book of law didn't sell either
check what the price is going for in the
morning to make sure you didn't make a
loss so on the Celtx cloak I didn't make
a loss it's about a 5k gain the Wizards
boots it's only a 10k gain
and the smoke battle staff unfortunately
was about a 10k loss which
up and sometimes they'll be prepared to
have a loss
but I went ahead and put it in for more
money than I bought it for and I just
let it sit to see if it would sell
you
I went ahead and checked the margin on
the iron knife to see how much I was
selling for so I could sell it for the
max price and it was selling for fifty
three coins
and then I decided to put in the guff
explode for
- Kay
to leave these items and let them sell
so all the items ended up selling I sold
the Wizards boots for 359 K the iron
knives for 201 K and the guthix cloaks
for 461 K on the iron knife so I made
about 40 K on the wizard boots I made 10
K and on the guv exclus I made almost
100 K so just for buying overnight and
selling in the morning I made 150 K my
next tip is bind from NPCs and selling
items you buy from them for more money
in the GE so the first NPC we're going
to go to is the dwarf from the dwarf
canon quest and that is the only
requirement you need is to do that quest
and as you can see the cannon is done
for 760 K and you can buy the cannon
from him for 750 K so teleport to the
monastery using a combat bracelet and
then run over here to the West I have
made a video on this before so I'll
leave a link in the description it's a
great moneymaker flipping cannons go
ahead and open the store and talk to the
dwarf and
bass bar so you can skip through the
chat and then click one hold down the
spacebar again
one and then hold down the spacebar
again
once you get the cannon pieces simply
drop all them on the floor and then
repeat the process
[Music]
once you have reached the max amount you
can buy go ahead and pick them all up
off the ground teleport to the grand
exchange turn them into sets and then go
ahead and put them into sell for the
price you want and then teleport back to
the monastery and repeat the process so
they all sold and to do all this it took
me 11 minutes the first you can insult
about instantly but the last seven took
a while to sell but anyways it took 11
minutes to do all of it buying and
selling them and I made 80k so that's
about 1 million GP per hour and
sometimes you can make even more than
that if the cannons are selling for more
or if the demand for cannons is higher
there are many NPCs and shops and stores
that you can buy from in the game to
make GP while flipping the items you buy
from them but another quick example that
I've also made a video about is buying
from the mages Amarok you can buy death
runes from him and the first few rooms
sell for 40 GP more in the GE and when
death rooms are selling for high this
method can make over a million GP per
hour my last tip is going to be buying
items and turning them into sets and
flipping them for more money so the item
I am using here is the book of law the
god books a lot of the barrows armor and
a lot of the Guddi hide all flip really
high when you flip the sets so that
means buying the items individually and
then turning them into a set and then
selling them for more so always make
sure to check the margins on the items
before turning them into a set and make
sure they sell for more when put as a
set and individually so here I'm buying
all the pages three out of the four
pages sold instantly but I could not get
the page 2 to buy instantly for the
price that it was going for so I decided
to up the price a lot because I would
still make lots of profit if I sold the
set so once you buy the items to make
the set go ahead and create the item
you
put it in the GE and make sure you are
making profit on the item so I sold it
for 16 45 K and I bought everything for
16 21 K so that was an easy 21 K profit
just by flipping a set so that concludes
my top 5 flipping tips and I hope that
video helped you guys learn how to flip
a little bit better some tips that I
didn't include in the video are make
sure when you're AF cane you're always
flipping at the same time because
there's no point in AF cane doing a
skill like fletching or wood cutting or
even training if you're not going to
make some extra money in the background
by flipping and also don't be afraid to
take risks sometimes you got to check
the margin on your own you got to buy
the item high and then sell low and see
that 20 K margin that you weren't aware
of I hope you guys like this video go
ahead and leave a comment if you have
another idea for a top 5 video for me to
make I have a few in mind but I would
love to hear your guys advice anyway
thanks guys for watching and stay tuned
for my next video
you